oh this is so funny dude I love this one
so this girl where everyone's first
impression of her is that
kind of got a dirty mind
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I mean the cliff notes were longer than
the actual [__] story so this is a
girl that once you meet her you thought
that she was gonna be really innocent
like she just was kind of a family you
know woman and like just kind of cool
and everything and like she has really
good friends and like just kind of a
normal chick but then you get to know
her and you notice that not only are
things a little bit odd but they're kind
of really odd like you look at her uh
social media posts and sometimes they're
cryptic and uh I realize her friends are
kind of from the wrong side of the Strat
tracks and also she didn't really uh
when you when you catch her like when
she doesn't know you're looking at her
she's doing some weird interesting stuff
and she's kind of got a dirty mind
instead of an innocent mind here we go
[__] you thought you was innocent but
just did hey dude
like so [__] long
this is a song about actually uh
sometimes I'm not really sure what I
want to eat
um and then I really just I'm like I
think about it I'm just like going over
things I'm switching between Postmates
and doordash and then like I'm just like
sometimes I even look at ubereats I
don't even really YouTuber eats that
much and they always mess up my location
but so I usually get Postmates but man
sometimes I just never really know what
I want to eat
um and I really just mostly pretty much
five nights out of the week I get pizza
I like pizza
dude that guy who is that we have to
look at more stuff from him
please who is it please find it
my my
who is it
he also sings good though that's the
thing
you found them
this guy's a guy who's always in stuff I
see his stuff and I love him
foreign
says okay but he's hot though yeah thank
God
[Music]
so good dude
so this is a story of a girl that
God and you [__] are listening that
and you're like this is gonna be a
banger
and then he comes out with that [__] God
damn it I want to know who that is
how about this
they don't add him yeah that's that's
hater [__] when they
okay
oh this was good this was good and
look
look at that Cody I knew what 14 15
years
uh
like what like singing and dancing yeah
yeah
[Music]
hahaha
this one's the best dude the [__]
best the smile at the end dude you have
to watch it
again
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude the [__] music dude holy [__]
not me man I just served
[Music]
thank you